I know that you are an East Coast guy
yeah and grew up there but boxing was
not previously part of your world oh
right so did you happen to see your own
self in Vinnie passes life in his story
I did very much I had I've been 12 years
as I've made a movie and in Hollywood
that's a very long time to not work for
and similar to vineya I was had there
were suggestions that I might not make
another movie in the way that there was
suggestions made to him that he might
not fight again once I sort of realized
that parallel strange I didn't when the
story was pitched to me but once I got
into writing it realized oh wait this is
my story that's when I decided to stay
on and direct originally were just a
writing assignment right well I know you
did many things in between that yeah I'm
after prime yeah did you get an airline
I got my pilot's license yeah I'm not an
ATP I can't fly passengers but I can fly
myself and friends I mean I can't I'm
not like an airline pilot or right yeah
I'm private pilot but but do you feel
that was in some ways beneficial for you
because or maybe not you were able to
stand back and re-evaluate things and
now look what you've created it's
amazing yeah no totally I've I know
people that I've left New York or and
come to LA to be screen writers and they
do lose a little something there is
there is something to be said for
getting out and living in the world
being a part of the world and having
experiences in a personal you know
communications between new people and
then that ends up finding its way on
screen even though I thought oh no all
my contemporaries are moving ahead
they're making all these movies while
I'm not I'm enjoying life but you know
am I is this gonna set am I gonna suffer
professionally but somehow it all ended
up on screen I think that's the elephant
in the room in the industry is that
people do have long I wouldn't say dry
spells but just for lack of a better
word and then something fantastic
happens so for you what advice would you
have to other people who still want to
be in the industry I think you looked at
scripts right you kept yourself
in terms of keeping a foot in I kept
writing I didn't realize I didn't read
but I was wrote so I would do script
rewrite script doctoring I sold a bunch
of pilots that's how I paid most largely
paid my bills so my advice would be
similarly to not stop writing if you're
just a director I actually I have
empathy because you're selling a skill
set that's not quantifiable but if you
write a screenplay and everybody
somebody wants it you have leverage you
have you own something a piece of
property that so I would say if you're a
writer just keep writing alright can we
talk about being in the Edit room and
cutting back between footage from your
film and the real-life Vinnie Paz
because you did it so seamlessly that
are there right hearts that you don't
know if it smiles if it's Benny love
hearing you say that yeah that was not
by design the truth is that we just
thought we would used archival footage
for the end credits
but when miles sort of completed his
transformation
he got so close to Vinnie his likeness
the way sounds that when we got the
editing room we've said let's just let's
try him let's try and cut directly to
the archived footage and middle of the
movie which should take people out of
the film and didn't and that's a
testament to Miles and the the
preparation work that he did yeah thank
you sure yeah